yeah how about when we were on shark
week and we got poopies and his dad meet
with my dad we're having this oh my god
that was so fun and the story is coming
out in front of my dad and poopy's dad
and you were driving it to be clear
but once you gave the green light to
tell like we told some of the filthiest
[ __ ] stories yeah
yeah i think poopy stuff was like what
the [ __ ] yeah it was it was a night in
in uh bombay
and and i
bombay india
also known as mumbai we're at this bar
and i meet this uh
this russian or not no sorry this
canadian lady at the bar she's like yeah
come on back tomorrow i'm like oh it's
on come on come on back to the
to be clear she was my friend's friend
oh really that's why she was there oh
damn she was your friend's friend and
she was married and she was married and
she was just a canadian expat living in
bombay in india so i'm like all right
[ __ ] man i come back to
to go back to her place
where it would be oh and
i was with one other person from the
crew it was me and another guy from the
crew right and so we're like kind of all
getting down you know like we're kind of
and i wasn't even
so she's servicing this other guy from
the crew and they're pretty high up in
the crew you know like like uh
and and in the in this woman's bedroom
it's this woman's on her knees this this
crew member's standing up all of a
sudden the bedroom door opens and it's
her husband well we don't know it's the
husband
yeah i mean
the guy is opening up the door to his
own bedroom and it is her husband and uh
i say we don't know right to be clear
this is not me right yeah it's not you
this this this crew member
the door opens the crew member says
dude get the [ __ ] out of here
it's in his own bedroom
and and the guy says hey man it's cool
i'll just watch
and then the crew member says
no dude it's not [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here
you were the only witness to that and
that we quoted that forever no dude it's
not [ __ ] cool were you laughing out
of here i'm just like i mean i can't
remember i mean i don't know i'm just
like i couldn't even believe it and then
and then the crew member and and in a
fit of frustration she's just like ah
[ __ ] i'm out of here and he takes off
so then like opportunity knocks for
steve
so i started getting getting in on it
and uh and i'm totally cool with the guy
watching like it was very hard he came
back in after the other guy left
i first he got kicked out of his own
bedroom but then when steve went he's
like hey dude it's cool
yeah i'm like dude it's cool
and it's very hard to get weed in india
yeah so so and this guy had weed so his
wife was servicing me while he's holding
this pipe up to my lips and lighting
jesus
and then and then he's like hey if you
want to have sex with my wife you know
like uh i i'll give you a condom and i'm
like right on dude so
it was the first time i ever had sex
with a bro with a married woman there
were certain lines i never crossed like
i never took anyone's virginity i had up
to that point never
i've been a part of adultery mm-hmm
yeah
and he got you weed gotta be high and i
burned his wife while he watched with
the rubber that he gave me that's pretty
gnarly yeah and then i got back
hopefully his rubber was better than
yours then i got back to the hotel room
at the sun's up
and i can i was sharing a room with jp
and jb i'll remember this forever
because i walked and i go jp i've been
to bad places and i've done bad things
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude